>>Emily: I believe there are a select
few who get to shape the world we live
in and that that's not right.
So, I want to have 16 year
old high school students
who are building 2,200
square foot farmers markets
that change the face of their home town.
I want to have 10 year old
girls who walk in fearful
and walk out having fused metal.
I think that what we're doing is
changing who gets to make the world.
>>Emily: So, I'm going to hold
it and you go really slowly,
and it's going to grab it and
tighten it in place for you.
>>Emily: I spent a lot of my childhood
in the woods building tree houses
and I have always felt
that there were things
that I was learning outside of school--
That I wasn't
able to access within school.
I came into the education space
with the training of an architect,
but a lot of the ideals and
passions of an educator.
I knew there were things about
architecture and design that had a place
and could have a deep
impact in a classroom.
They can sand this out, that's easy.
>>Emily: And then, it's
one, two, three, four holes.
So that is what inspired me to leave
a very traditional architecture
and design path, and instead
start my own non-profit.
Project H Design to give young people a
physical space, and the physical tools
to make things and ideas real, and
prove that a program like this can live
in a K through 12 public space.
The students that I've worked with,
come to us with such different stories,
whether these are 10 year old
girls who I'm teaching how to weld,
or they're 17 year olds who are living
in not so great family situations.
I want them to leave my class
feeling like whatever that thing is,
it's not an obstacle to
their success and happiness.
So, what motivates me and what is so
rewarding is watching the transformation
from that moment of fear or
hesitation to a moment of confidence,
accomplishment, and what's next.
I think that maker based
learning really sticks with kids
because it's not just the act
of making that is important,
it's knowing why you're making
something, and for whom.
>>Teacher: Great, great job.
I really appreciate all the
work you guys did today.
One, two, three.
>>Emily: It is a challenge back onto
the educational community to continue
to push on the things we offer to
kids within the school walls, and say,
it doesn't have to look like
standardized testing all day long.
It can look like architecture
built by 16 year olds.
We say that we're never bored and
we're never done, and I'm certainly,
neither of those two things.